breaking news forgetting from the PA
news wire that there's been reports on
an explosion outside Liverpool Street
Station that of course in the East End
of London it's the the bordering area
you'll be may be familiar with the Swiss
building known as the the gherkin which
of course has been a familiar landmark
throughout London for the past couple of
years or so that's they're very close to
Liverpool Street Station getting this
reports of an explosion from the British
Transport Police yeah no more
information at the moment no details of
whether the police had been informed of
a warning of course it comes just after
the rush hour ended 9 o'clock most
people at work probably by now but
emergency services so assuming the fire
brigade ambulance service as well and
indeed British Transport Police are
going to London's Liverpool Street
Station after reports thereof an
explosion is one of the busiest links at
this time of day within London all the
people coming out of Essex and that sort
of area all commuting into London all
arriving at Liverpool Street Station
there's a whole hub of course of
underground stations as there many
people use it for leaks into the city of
London it's often one of the best ways
in from there but it is one of the
busiest areas that we know within London
the latest forgetting is from the London
Ambulance Service telling us that
they've sent resources out to the scene
by that they mean a number of vehicles
have been sent to Liverpool Street
Station no further details of what could
have caused this explosion what it could
be how big it's been or indeed at this
time whether there have been any
injuries but of course the ambulance
service telling us that it has sent a
number of vehicles to Liverpool Street
Station in the last few minutes this
station has us you'll no doubt
understand being close now this morning
eyewitnesses say there was a bang heard
during rush hour of course now it's
slightly after rush hour that's
according to British Transport Police
the noise could have been power related
is some speculation we're hearing from
Reuters and those still early days and
officers are attending the scene but
clearly a bang was heard in the last
hour or so at Liverpool Street Station
down in central London but it
to be power-related so not necessarily
an explosion there in London's financial
district one would ex